I wonder if we re-ran the 20th century a
thousand times if how many times the
Soviet Union will collapse
yeah I wonder about that too and I also
wonder about what would have happened if
it didn't collapse and Gorbachev had
found a different direction
I mean you know we see a very divisive
time now in American history the United
States of America has very different
cultures very different uh beliefs
ideologies within those States but those
are that's that's kind of the strength
of America's there's these little
Laboratories of ideas until though that
they don't keep together I mean I've had
colleagues who have described what's
happening in the west right now was a
kind of soft secession with States you
know going off in their own Direction
well you know these kinds of conceptions
that we have now are divisions between
red and blue States because of the
fracturing of our politics
and I'd always thought that that
wouldn't be possible in someone like the
United States or um you know many other
countries as well because it wasn't that
ethnic
um uh Dimension but in fact many of our
the way that people talk about politics
has given it that kind of appearance in
many respects because look I mean we
know from the Soviet Union and the
Soviet period and from where you're from
you know originally in Ukraine that
language is not the meant to signify of
identity and that identity can take all
kinds of of other forms that's really
interesting I mean but
there has to be a deep grievance of some
kind if you took a poll in any other
states in the United States I think a
very small minority people would want to
actually succeed uh even in Texas where
I spend a lot of my time yeah I I just I
think that there is a common kind of
pride of nation
you know there's a a lot of people
complain about government and about how
the country's going the way people
complain about the weather when it's
raining they say oh this stupid weather
it's raining again but really what they
mean is
we're in the Smock together there's a
together there that I I also feel that
when I go around because I mean I've
spent a lot of time since I've
um my book in last October and this last
year going around I find I find the same
feeling but you know when I traveled
around the Soviet Union
back in the late 1980s I didn't get any
kind of sense that people wanted to see
the end of the Soviet Union either it
was an elite project there's a um a
really good book called Collapse by
vladislav zubuck who is a professor
um at um London School of Economics at
LLC and zubock is pretty much my age and
he's from you know the former Soviet
Union's Russian and I mean he describes
it very quite aptly about how it was
kind of the elites you know that
basically decided to pull the Soviet
Union apart and there is a risk of that
you know here as well when you get
parties on politics and people
forgetting you know they're Americans
and they are all in this together like a
lot of the population thing but they
think that they're on you know narrower
parties on our ideological precepts you
know camp for more and in the Soviet
case was also a power play
you know in a way that actually can't
quite play out in the United States
because it was the equivalent of
Governors in many respects who got
together three of them you know in the
case of
um the heads of Russia Ukraine and
Belarus who then you know got rid of you
know the basically the central
um the central figure of Michael
Gorbachev it would be a little difficult
to do that the dynamic is not the same
but it does worry me of having seen all
of that close up
in the late 1980s and the early 90s and
I was I spent you know a lot of time in
the uh in Russia uh as well as in
Ukraine and caucus and Central Asia and
you know other places after the collapse
of the Soviet Union but you you kind of
see the same Elite divisions here in the
United States pulling
in you know in different uh in different
directions and straining you know the
overall body politic and the way that
National politics gets imposed on local
politics in ways that it certainly
wasn't when I first came to the US in
1989 I didn't honestly in 1989 when I
first came here I didn't know anybody's
political affiliation I mean I rarely
knew their religious affiliation and and
you know obviously race was a was a
major phenomenon here that was a shock
to me when I when I first came but many
of the kind of the class Regional
Geographic you know kind of political
Dimensions that I've seen in other
places I didn't see them at play in the
same way then as I do now